this is a production of cornell
university
okay thanks very much neil i'm not going
to talk about everything i did in the
last 40 years
because it would take about 40 years
thanks bill i would
uh when talked to neil about the
possibly doing this we thought it might
be interesting to take a little more
philosophical type of approach rather
than just showing a lot of data
and uh talk about you know over a career
what some of the lessons are that you
learn
that you wish you knew at the beginning
of your career
so i put this together some of the
latter parts going to be sort of
miscellaneous observations but
they hopefully they might be of some
some use to somebody
so first of all when you get started on
doing research
uh one of the questions that we don't
sort of ask ourselves
implicitly but we actually do is so how
am i going to actually do this
what type of approach should i use for
research and
i heard a talk from success from the
australian wine research institute and
he uh
he showed this example of different
types of research
and his little matrix with research
inspired by fundamental understanding
with a yes or no and then research
inspired utility
by utility or or application yes or no
so
when you look at these of course you got
four quadrants he called one of them
bores after niels bohr the uh
physicist where it's pursued a
fundamental understanding
uh alone without any immediate
application and
that's uh you know basically basic
research which is
fine and is something that's very
important uh
kitty corner from that is the edison's
quadrant
which is uh pursuit of practical utility
but
not necessarily uh with an understanding
in mind but a
trial and error approach which has also
been very
useful but he felt and i i agree that uh
probably the most useful approach
is what he called pasteur's approach
and that is integrated approach for a
fundamental understanding
and practical utility together and so if
you can do both of those and integrate
them then
i think that's a preferable way of
course you want to avoid the joker's
quadrant
of no value in either direction so
from saki's paper
he basically said that the pasteurian
research is what's needed
towards increasing fundamental
understanding and
i think the important thing in a context
responsive to applied needs
at levels of both problem selection and
experimental design
now for us this i think this fits uh
the horticultural area i think we can
learn
the fundamental understanding but if
it's in the context of a real problem
i think we gain in both directions so um
and then uh that usually if you have
that type of approach you're going to
try to understand
the physiological principle behind
things and so
emerson had a nice quote that i think
summed it up nicely the value of a
principle
is in the number of things that will
explain
okay and uh another way of looking at it
is
that if you have a system where for
example
environmental responses of
of plants that if you have a
physiological principle of the plant
here in the middle it will interact with
different
environmental conditions so the weather
a
is might be a one year whether b might
be a different year
the interaction between the
physiological principle and the
environment will give an
outcome now in one year it might be dry
and you'll get a certain outcome and
another year it might be wet
and you'll get a different outcome
so the outcomes will vary along with the
with the inputs but the physiological
principle
doesn't change and so if you can
understand that
you're going to be much better at being
able to predict what's going to happen
or explain what happened
and in many cases if we do field trials
you know in different years we get
different results and that doesn't
always make a lot of sense
unless you understand the the principle
that is
interacting and uh you're giving a
different manifestation of the
that final outcome so um
again i've i really tried to focus on
understanding what the physiological
principles are
be behind the growth and development and
performance of primarily grapes and
apples that i've worked with over the
years
okay so my research goals really
is to uh been to understand the
environmental and physiological
limitations
to both the basic biological uh as well
as the economic
productivity of grapes and tree fruits
especially
apples but also to utilize that in
information collaboratively with
colleagues like
terence robinson and others to
to use that information to improve the
productivity or the performance
or the efficiency sustainability of
of our tree performance and the cultural
practices that we
that we use again i i'm emphasizing
primarily light or energy uh carbon and
water relations
uh but i i try to in uh integrate those
with
information like from la lang chang on
nutrition and and
other other disciplines but that's
that's the area that i'm
focusing in um
okay instead of going through all the
details i thought i'd give
maybe three examples of some work that
started out asking fundamental questions
and ended up giving some practical
outcomes and one of them is
about i was wondering about apple trees
how much
dry matter they produce over the season
what's really controlling that
things like different climates why can
new zealand produce twice the fruit that
we can
you know what what's really controlling
uh the productivity from a carbon
uh standpoint and then because of that
study over the years we gradually
developed a simulation model that i'll
talk about that has actually become
useful for growers
so that's one example another one
is in terms of water use by apples
and you know the need for potential
irrigation
i wanted to really understand you know
how how much
does the apple tree use because it has
some unusual characteristics
and what is what controls it under our
type of conditions
and that eventually led to an apple
specific
penman-monteith equation for water use
that is now being used by growers as
well
and then finally uh a nagging question
with water relations over the years is
how can we try to measure uh and
continuously monitor
the water relations of plants perennial
plants are
are particularly dynamic in their water
relations
and so it's so dynamic that just taking
a reading once a week
isn't going to give you a very good uh
overall
view so you know looked into that and
how we can possibly do that and
um so the sensor that uh vinay has been
working on
uh is an example of of the outcome of
that
so let me try to run through these
in the carbon balance area
some of the more specific questions
beyond just how much
dry matter does an apple tree produce in
the season
we're interested in what are the dynamic
patterns over the season
and during those different patterns
because not everything is
the demand and supply doesn't always
stay exactly in balance
are there key periods where there might
be a carbon deficit
and is there anything we could do about
that and so
we took a lot of field measurements
down in the lower left corner you can
see we've used the whole canopy balloon
chambers
we have in some cases
had as many as 45 days during a season
that we measured
measured them but we've done a lot of
single leaf and fruit development
measurements
but a lot of a lot of spot measurements
over the season
but we'd like to try to integrate those
uh better
and so we ended up developing a
simulation model which i'll
show next about the
carbon balance of apples with malasim or
vitasim as the grape version
and we found over the years that it was
very important to to
go iteratively between the measurements
and the modeling
because the the modeling helps you
integrate the measurements
but then you can also get some wild
values if you're
if you're not always checking against
real measurements with the modeling
so i found that modeling and measurement
uh
really fit together well and i think
i was far better off doing both of them
rather than
one or the other okay
so i won't go through all of it but this
is basically a carbon balance
model we're trying to look for the
carbon supply
and of course that depends on the
sunlight available and
what's intercepted and leaf
photosynthesis to convert it
into dry matter and of course many of
the things around the outside
are factors that kind of influence those
um
and then we looked at the total demand
of respiration and growth
of the different parts of the plant
and then this gives a general carbon
supply demand
balance which we found very useful but
we also have components for fruit drop
and partitioning which don't really have
time to go into but
it's as simplified a model as possible
although it still ends up being
relatively complex to
to put it together so when we did
to take a look at what was going on we
could estimate that the
supply uh in in the blue here
uh you know initially dips because of
reserves
being used up so this is current supply
current photosynthesis
and then peaks in the middle of the
season and then gradually drops off with
the
shorter days and less radiation
but the demands these more solid lines
are the
general demand curves for a normal crop
of fruit and then a heavier crop being
so there is some carbon deficit during a
good part of the season
but with apples since you have a 10 to
20 times more
flowers producing initial fruit than you
actually want to take to harvest
if all those fruit stayed on the demand
curve
is this purple one this initial crop
that just skyrockets and goes
crazy because a tree might have two
thousand fruit and you want two hundred
so those two thousand fruit really take
off
and you can see that in the couple weeks
after bloom
a week to three weeks after bloom is
where you get a really dramatic
carbon deficit of course that's right at
a time during a
natural fruit drop and then also during
the response to chemical thinning
so that sort of gave us a hint something
there was a physiological basis for some
of those
things so using these types of
simulations not trying to be too precise
but looking at general patterns
and see when maybe the supply and demand
might be in balance or might be out of
balance
was very helpful to focus our research
right into that
time period where there's normally a
tendency to you know
have equally spaced readings over a
season
um in the last probably last 10 or 15
years i'm
i've almost never taken any readings
after a month after bloom
because i know what's going to happen
the all the action really is occurring
early and so we do
follow up with some readings later but
uh
but the action is occurring at that time
so the model helped us really identify
this
and so help focus our research to be
more efficient
it also turned out at that time if you
measure the measure a lot of fruit we
measured the fruit growth of
probably 10 or 12 000 fruits over the
years
during the that post bloom period
what we find is that the general pattern
is that
if the fruits are growing at a high rate
uh usually something like 60 or 70
percent of
the maximum rate that you would have at
that time under those conditions
they will stay on the tree if the fruit
stop
growing or slow their growth
dramatically
they're going to fall off and
it may be 10 14 days later before they
actually fall off
but we can tell by monitoring the fruit
usually within three or four days out
if we're very careful within three or
four days after
say a chemical thinner or maybe a really
shady
or low light period we can tell which
ones
are going to fall off maybe 10 days
later
because it to be retained they have to
continue growth
uh continue at a high growth rate now we
we make it
as a fraction of the fastest growing
fruit because if it's colder
everything's going to grow somewhat
slower so
the absolute rate isn't isn't so
important
so we have incorporated this into the
end of the model for a drop of fruit
but this is what's occurring at that
time when you have a carbon deficit
so working with terrance we're saying
well you know we have some years that we
get
you know we get a big heavy drop natural
drop and we get a strong response
to chemical thinners other years we put
the
same thinner on same time same stage of
development and
you get very little drop you know so
chemical thing has been very
very erratic the
the growers know that if you go out and
do exactly the same thing
put on the same chemical same time same
stage same orchard you're going to get
different results every year
which is sort of like the definition of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over but expecting different results
so so we thought well let's try to bring
some sanity to this
and see if the model might be able to
help us
understand that so
i started looking to see whether the
model might help us
understand natural drop for example
and this was an example from in uruguay
when i was there
i happened to be there right about the
time that there was
a lot of fruit drop and normally apples
will drop at a much smaller size
than that but we were having fruit that
were some of them were up to 24
millimeters in size
they had a heavy initial set and they
just kept growing and growing and
growing
and then there was a huge drop and it
just
the industry lost about 30 percent of
its normal
it was 70 of normal crop and it
occurred just before all the hand
thinning that was supposed to be done by
50 000 workers there who all all of a
sudden were out of a job
and when we looked at the we ran their
weather data
through the carbon balance model and
what we found was at this
early initial critical time the uh
in blue here you can see the circle that
we had abnormally good
carbon balance and when we have that we
see that the fruit don't fall off
because they're all able to continue
growing or
much greater proportion can continue to
grow
so we ended up having a lot of quite
large fruit
then they had five really cloudy days
they weren't particularly hot or
anything but they were just very cloudy
days that they didn't really think much
about
you know it was a cloudy week you know
well it was very cloudy
and the carbon deficit just went really
through the
through the floor and we find in this uh
this orange band here this is roughly
sort of our threshold
for having a strong effect so it can
bounce around above that
but if it goes below that you're going
to probably see a strong
reduction and this occurred right about
the time these were
just really having a huge uh demand
and uh so when you have five or six days
of really reduced growth
then you're going to have a huge drop so
it looks like it can help explain
natural
drop okay so then yes
um i think that was somewhere in the 30
to 40 percent
of normal radiation which
is not abnormal it was
uh i mean we we'll see that overcast you
know fairly heavy overcast
uh the real key was that it was like
five days in a row
because one day doesn't really do much
to apples two days a little bit three
days you
really have a strong effect and more
even more so
um so it looked like natural drop could
could relate to the carbon balance um
and then terence had been doing some
studies where he was putting on
uh chemical thinners exactly the same
concentration
but about every four days on an orchard
not not the same trees obviously uh so
he wanted to see what the timing was
and he would find that one year the best
thinning occurred maybe the first week
after bloom
another one it would be three weeks
after bloom another one two weeks after
bloom
uh and it was really erratic you
couldn't couldn't specifically
guess as to when it was going to be so
he had this data
on timing and so we started looking
we've got many different years but
there's an example where the
zero line means the carbon is in balance
so anything above is excess and below
his deficit so
i found that everything was pretty much
in balance
um until we uh we got hit
about 17 to 20 days after
so we had some i was warm and cloudy
and then we had another big dip and it
uh so we found that when we put the
thinner on at that time
we got the strongest thinning now that's
been observed many times by growers so
it's not
they know if it's warm and cloudy you're
going to have a strong thinner response
but
it did seem to correlate with the carbon
balance so
we've tested this
and so the way we're using this
uh i didn't really put the r there but
thanks bill gates um
any case the uh the way we're using this
model
is uh we're using it similar to the
penman-monteith equation
for evapotranspiration where you have a
standard
reference plant like their standard
grass
and which the parameters are set but
then you put in the weather for
different years or different periods
and then you can see what does the
weather do to that standard plant
and so that's the basis of a lot of the
estimation of
evapotranspiration that is uh used and
we'll i'll talk about a little bit later
so we're basically doing the same thing
uh with the
with the apple model and having a quote
standard tree
and then we can put in weather from
different climates and different
years or different treatments if you put
a shade on for example
and then we can see what that would do
to say a carbon reference
and so terence started using this for
growers
where he was before he went out to speak
to the growers right at
the beginning of thinning he would run
the model
and then he would look for something
like a very strong deficit
here in the circle on the bottom here uh
where the
where it looked like it was going to be
a significant deficit during that
sensitive period and he was able to warn
some of the growers
uh that there was you know a severe
deficit coming
be careful about maybe using the same
normal concentration
perhaps reduce the concentration of
thinners
and over the years that that turned out
that it was very very helpful
and the growers had become much more
confident about
about their thinning using this type of
model
and uh people from all over the world
are
testing this now and working with it but
for the
new york growers uh we worked with the
climate center with
art digatano and keith eggleston
and we we put a the carbon balance model
we translated it jim myers one of our
ex-students justine's postdoc
some of his time was we purchased to
translate the model into an excel
version and then also into python for
an online version so what we can do now
is the grower can go in
select their weather station from the
automated weather stations and put in
information on the
when the trees begin to grow to start
the model
and then the uh then the output shows
the
it only needs maximum minimum
temperatures and solar radiation for
each day
so it's the daily time step so you get
the data there and then it gives the
production of demand
and the carbon balance uh and there's a
four-day running average because the
tree buffers out
you know like one day i won't do it
there's a buffering
and then terence has developed thinning
recommendations based
on what type of carbon deficit we're
looking at
so this is being used currently we have
growers and consultants that actually
have the model themselves and have been
running them and
one of the growers was reporting that he
was able to reduce his
post thinning hand thinning bill
because he normally was he wasn't
comfortable with the chemical
so i was used a little less and he
always had too many fruit so then he had
to
pay for extra hand thinning so he had
reduced this hand thinning from
about a hundred thousand dollars a year
down to about 20 000 a year
so they're you know it's a it's a
critical time
and it's a important process to get that
uh right so
uh so this has been helpful and we have
we have collaborators in many different
countries that are
working with it and so we want to
develop this further and
and have a website that others from
around the world can
input their own weather data directly
and then have it run the
simulation model so this is one that
over
we began with the model in 1988
so it's a overnight process as you can
tell
but you know gradually you have to keep
plugging away
okay another one is about the
area of how much water you know do
apple trees need and use and uh you know
factors that control it
um a couple of the observations that
sort of led to the
uh development here one is that a long
time ago in 1980 or so i was
working with a colleague in germany and
and we found that the
stomates of apples seem to have an
unusual response to
vapor pressure deficit um
and in the in the field in the
greenhouse or
growth chamber it's completely different
but in the field they don't seem to be
very sensitive to the vapor pressure
deficit
it's really controlled by the
photosynthesis they're highly coupled to
the photosynthesis
uh and then this tied together with
terence's observations from
irrigation trials that if he used
the normal thing using that monteith et
reference and then a fraction of that
the crop coefficient
for estimating apple water use and
in some years we're greatly over
irrigating
even though we're using this what it's
supposed to be so
we're trying to figure out well why why
aren't the trees using as much as we
expected
and so let's see if we can put this
together
uh so a student danilo dragoni
about 10 years ago or so
came worked with us he was a
microclimatologist
he really didn't know much about
horticulture and i'm not sure he learned
a huge amount about horticulture but
he did some really good work for us on
uh
understanding what's going on and so
he did a lot of measurements again using
sap flow gauges in the field
and we calibrated them with the balloons
and
so went through the season the crop
coefficient is the fraction of that
reference
that's actually used what we would find
is some you know from day to day we
would see it might be up to 90 or 96
percent
and then other days it'd be down to like
45 percent
so huge variations from day to day that
you know we're trying to figure out what
what actually is uh
going on here why why isn't that it's
supposed to be fairly constant
because the reference is supposed to
adjust to the weather
so we had to we
we thought well shockingly grass
is maybe not a good model of an apple
tree so
we thought well maybe we need to back up
and rather than
using a wrong model and then taking a
fraction of a wrong model
we might be better off just taking the
original pendant monteith equation
of all the physics and then
making our own apple specific version of
that
and uh and we did that as if
danilo did that i'll take credit of
course but um
the this the model response curve here
um turns out that in very dry conditions
the
the stomate do close due to high
evaporative demand
but under moderately dry
all the way to very humid conditions it
doesn't respond anymore
to the vapor pressure deficit so if we
use the pendulum on teeth equation we
had to put in a very different boundary
layer
of air because a an apple orchard is
very very
a lot of turbulent flow so you don't
have that still air or like you do over
grass
and then we had to adjust because the
trees don't
always intercept 100 of the light like a
grass would
and then secondly uh or finally we had
to put in this unusual stomatal response
and when we did we got a very very good
model
that fit the fit the data very nicely
and so from that then we've
again gone back to work with art and
keith and
and have an apple uh et model specific
it turns out that humid conditions are
the situation where that
that traditional system doesn't work
very well
so again the growers can choose their
own location
and the data is put in directly and then
the model calculates the
estimated water use and a
and a water balance for the growers
okay so so this is the
the output from that um chosen for
say williamson in this particular case
so the growers can put in their spacing
and
descriptions of the orchard so it can be
adjusted for
um if it's a young orchard it'll be
smaller
so um so now
again just studying how still mates
respond to humidity
has eventually led to a uh a useful tool
which is online for growers
okay and then
another final one that i want to
talk about a bit is that when you work
with apple
and grapes and tree fruits and all you
know forest trees also
uh one of the one of the real issues
with uh
with understanding the water stress in
these types of
systems well there's really two issues
one is that
the roots of these
different types of perennial plants tend
to be
quite erratic they can be they can be
very
uniform so this is this is grape roots
uh this is from south africa a couple
pictures here
uh this is in a very very uniform
friable soil
you know about four feet deep and you
can see the roots distribute rather
nicely
but especially grape roots are
they don't have any inherent structure
just the way the top doesn't
so they will go wherever the conditions
are best
and because of that if you happen to
have a plow pan
like here or a hard plant pan or uh
you know maybe a perch water table or
things like that those root systems will
go wherever
the conditions are best and you can't
really predict that very well
and we've dug up a lot of grape roots
and you know you
uh you just don't know where they are so
first of all then trying
on a deep erratic root system you know
where do you put your soil moisture
sensor
and uh so if you use soil moisture
you're never sure exactly where to put
it and
we found that even things like neutron
probe that take a big
sample only
very generally will respond
very well to the soil moisture and say
the photosynthesis or the
or the water potential of the of the
plant
um so that's one issue where are the
roots and
you know they may be in different parts
of the soil with different conditions so
the other the other thing is that
because of the hydraulic resistance
with a like especially in apple trees or
beaches things like that the hydraulic
resistance is fairly high
in these types of plants what that means
is that
the water potential in the top of the
plant
depends not only on the soil but also on
the evaporative demand
so if you have two days with the same
soil moisture
if one of them is a sunny breezy warm
dry day the water potential might go to
minus 20 bars
the next day if it's overcast and humid
and cool
it may only go to seven bars even though
you have exactly the same soil
so because of that need the importance
of the evaporative demand
to these perennials we'd like to be able
to measure it directly
in the plant rather than trying to
indirectly measure it in the soil
so of course we use pressure bombs
pressure chambers excuse me
especially if you're having on on an
airplane
but we so we we go in but obviously
it's sort of like taking your blood
pressure you know once every
week or two weeks you know you get an
instantaneous reading
and then the rest of the time it might
be going crazy it depends on whether you
just got a grant or just got refused
you know from a grant so you know your
blood pressure and the and the water
status of these uh
uh plants is very dynamic so if you have
a dynamic system you want to be able to
measure
very often uh so we need to try to do a
continuous measurement
versus you know say a one-time
measurement once a week or two weeks
so we'd like to be able to do something
where we can
monitor this continuously and
it's also a fairly large drop
in the water potential during the day
and of course the water
status of the plant makes a big
difference in terms of growth
and the size of fruit the quality of
fruit and especially in
wine grapes it's very important for
flavor development
and wine quality and in many cases
especially with red grapes
having an intermediate stress is the
optimum not
not having too little stress and
you don't want too much stress and shut
don't shut the whole plant down so it
can't
ripen the crop so if you want to have an
intermediate
stress in a very dynamic situation
you've got to have a lot of measurements
so we'd like to be able to make a more
of a continuous measurement so
the approach that we use and this is in
collaboration with
abe strook who i think we'll be talking
next week right
he's a microfluidics
physics engineer in chemin biomolecular
engineering
who's been interested in water and
plants and
under tension so we had an idea
and worked with abe and developed a
design and uh
vinay has been working for the last 24
years or something you've been here
uh oh four excuse me uh
i'm putting this together uh so
the basic concept is that we have a
a normal potentiometer that's been used
uh the water and as it's pulled out of
this the soil pulls water out you set up
a
tension the problem is that of course
these fail
with almost a bar is about the maximum
range that you get if we're going to do
this inside a plant we need to go to
20 or 30 bars type of range
so the idea here is to take the same
concept of the tensiometer
but make a uh make a small chip
that actually is a micro version of the
tensiometer
but with uh with the uh tiny tiny
tubes and a tiny uh volume in there what
um
renee what's the volume in the is it
like
less than a microliter of water in there
because of these extremely tiny volumes
and and all the
wall effects uh you can have a much
greater range than you do in a big macro
potentiometer so
uh so we've been working uh we started
in 2007
again got to be persistent to have
overnight success
so we've developed and this is uh sort
of the latest version
of the micro tensiometer
and the idea being that we'll embed that
directly into the
into the wood the trunk of the vine or
the tree
and it's electronic so we have a we have
an output
that we can electronically monitor
they're also
they're made by uh using it's called
microelectromechanical systems or mems
technology which is sort of like chips
integrated circuits but the next
generation integrated devices
so
there's vinay in the in the cornell
nano nanofab facility
very fashionable bunny suits there
and so he's working with you know a lot
of very expensive equipment which
occasionally works
and making uh very small devices that
can be produced on wafers
by robotic uh you know chip type
manufacturer
and uh there are factories this is
there's actually one in
uh it's called in photonics in canada
that can do that type of work
so the idea being that we can not only
have a sensor that is
a very large range i think the maximum
we've been able to calibrate up to or
down to about what 200 bars
tension i'm sorry 320 bars
tension uh is the
so we have about 320 times the range
that the macros
tensiometer has and so it's
you know it's a huge huge increase in
that so we're
trying to we're working on the packaging
trying to get this sensor into
forms that we can get into soils and
into
uh into plants uh but it it does work so
uh this is the uh uh this is where we're
going and it looks
it looks quite promising we're and we've
got a lot of interest
uh because there's a good possibility of
potentially a great improvement in the
ability to monitor
the water stress and optimize the
irrigation efficiency
and we hope because of that type of
manufacturer with robots and
you know like chip manufacturer reduces
price uh
quite dramatically so we're hoping the
prices can be quite low
and and then agriculture is a huge user
of water
and so if we can make even a one percent
change in the amount of water use
that can be a very big uh change in
total
so uh those are three of the
uh types of projects that i think you
know starting out
just trying to understand the
fundamental behavior of the plant
uh then but within the context of how
plants are working in the field and how
we're managing them
i think uh is is good to be able to get
that
information into a usable form for
growers
okay so i'd like to just go through
just a bunch of sort of miscellaneous
thoughts and
and uh things that i think i've learned
over the years
okay the these things that seem to have
either have or
potentially will have a biggest impact
they dealt with a fundamental
understanding but within the integrated
nature of
the plants in the natural environment
because
at least apples and grape you put them
in a growth chamber they're not the same
they you know some things are the same
but a lot of in terms of
carbon water those sorts that's more
what i think of as a
quantitative physiology depends a lot on
the environment
and where there's other things like say
phenological stage
beginning of ripening of grapes that's
something that will happen in
in all different conditions so i think
studying the plant in the
natural environment and how we manage it
i think was important as a context
for the the work uh i didn't have any
particular
uh use in mind but i was working
on the physiology of an important
process
i didn't know how it was going to work
but i i
you know was aware of what the process
was and what the problem was in the
field
and i think again that gives a context
that's useful
and the other thing was that none of
those things were well funded
matter of fact none of them were the
even the micro sensor which seems
obvious uh i think it was 12
i can't remember it's the 12th grant
proposal that i wrote that actually
finally got funded so
a lot of times these things if you're
studying still mates
nobody else thinks that you know that's
going to be very useful
at least not generally in our field so
uh so i think it's important to
not be you know if if you think it's
important
try to find some time you know to work
on it even if you can't get grants
i know that's much more difficult to say
now but
but i think it's still true
team research really is critical if
you're going to work on complex issues
because there's so many different
aspects that you need to be aware of so
uh i this is i'm not showing pictures of
everybody but
uh you know terence has done so much
with us for
a lot of the apple work dave eisenstadt
at penn state we
did a lot of work together with root
biology and understanding that
and abe stroke and chem
engineering bring in different expertise
not only expertise but then also from
more
basic and more fundamental to applied an
extension that's
equally important too and then it's
important to find
really good people to work with to
carry these things out so a couple of
the technicians that i've had
steve denning and uh currently rick
piccione
and rick dunstad and fredonia and we've
had
visiting scientists and students over
the years that have done a
huge amount of extra work and just a
few of those to represent that uh
important group
okay some general observation i think
one thing that we tend to fall a trap we
fall into is
is we come up with hypotheses and they
become our babies
you know and there's this tendency to
to really do all you can to prove the
hypothesis
you know because as you came up with it
and you you know you want you want to be
successful
um but i think this too often we end up
sort of either uh designing experiments
that are more likely to give supporting
information where really what we need to
do
is we need to be our harshest critics
we need to do our damnedest to refute
the hypothesis
because it's our hypothesis we know it
best and
so we should really really try our best
to disprove it
and if you can't you've got something
pretty good
if you say well okay well can we come up
with a condition or situation
in which that's not going to work and
if you can then there's probably
something wrong with that hypothesis
maybe you need to either throw it out or
or
modify it but if you if you keep working
through
by trying to disprove these things i
think in the end you're going to come up
with a much stronger
uh hypothesis that that again will be
closer to that principle that
that emerson said will be able to
explain a lot of things
so i think there's this tendency and
again
i think it may be tied in with the um
with the need to get grants
you know we're writing grant proposal
we're having to be salesmen
to always trying to sell our our idea to
a
granting agency something like that and
so it tends to put us into a positive
support kind of a thing but
scientifically we need to do the
opposite
and so i think we have to be careful not
falling into that
trap um the other thing uh nelson
charles
here that um a few of you may have met
is
uh he was our famous viticulturist and
really the father of canopy management
and
in grapes but he was also a very wise
man and
and he really was constantly beating on
us about
be specific about what you're talking
about
and so things like vigor when he was in
the room you were not allowed to use the
term vigor
because uh it wasn't clear what it meant
uh you know you talk to people sometimes
the best way to get
to really focus in on something is
asking what the what the units are
you say vigor okay what's the units
uh you know then it forces you to be
more specific and you know things like
crop load
there's a lot of different ways of
saying crop load and uh
resistance tolerance quality you know
quality
is not an attribute of the of the
product
you know it's the interaction of that
product with the expectations of the
user that's
quality so in a lot of cases we don't
measure quality
we might measure attributes related to
quality but
so it just be try to be more
specific and uh and
try not to use so many vague terms or if
you use them at least define them
and aristotle had a nice generalities of
the refuge of weak minds
that's maybe a little harsh but uh
that's
that's the uh i think the main point
uh of course we you know we have to
we have to continually use all the tools
that we can
and uh use them but i i think again in
our
situation i think it's very important to
use those in the context
of understanding the whole plant in the
in the environment that is actually
growing especially if we're
we're specifically interested in you
know horticultural crops that we're
growing
and so molecular biology is really
important to help elucidate
what's going on underneath and we worked
with susheng
on understanding what low light actually
does
and it and it really does change
the chemistry and biochemistry of the
of the plant and it and it helps really
give a much better understanding
i think it by itself isn't going to be
as valuable as as
in context with all the plant physiology
too
uh and engineering technologies as i've
learned
working with abe really have us allow us
to measure things that we had never
really thought about
i know taren's doing work with ct
scanning to be able to look at
things that we could never see before so
i think those are really important to
take those again in context with what
our problems are
and so
i think we need to move along here um
okay these are just some
just some quotes that i think i've sort
of collected that i think are
useful intelligent person is not he who
has the answers but he who knows what
questions ask
and the real voyage of discovery lies
not in seeking new
lands but in seeing with new eyes uh
you know we need to be able to get the
same information that everyone else sees
and see something different in it than
everyone else sees
and actually in our area especially
palmology and viticulture
shamans pointed out he said we should
look for unquestioned answers
as much as for unanswered questions
because we have a lot of dogma and you
look behind it and there's
many times very little scientific basis
behind it maybe one
one paper or something and then there's
there's a concept called contradictory
results
and i think basically i don't think
there are such things
i think they're really reflecting our
inadequate understanding of what the
governing principle is
of that system because if you know what
the principle is
then the results may be different but
they're not contradictory
as i pointed out earlier so um
anyway enthusiasm this is another
important one
um there's not a lot of really
there's not a lot of nobel winners that
weren't pretty darn enthusiastic about
what they were doing
and that enthusiasm is is really
important
and i i thought churchill was talking
about science here you know
success of the ability to go from one
failure to another with no loss of
enthusiasm
and so i think that's very important for
us
anyway so we don't i don't need to read
all those but
another thing is that as i mentioned
earlier i think it's quite important to
do modeling
and even if you never actually come out
with a mathematical and you know a
final output i think the process of
trying to say well what is this system
what are the components of this system
you know just drawing a modeling diagram
i think is a very
useful thing because you begin to see
interrelationships that you hadn't
thought about before
and so um i think it's important though
to
remember since they're all great
simplifications
that all models are wrong
but some models are useful so the
important thing is to focus on
usefulness not on the absolute
perfection of a model
because models can never be perfect or
they wouldn't be a model because
you'd have everything described so and
then
einstein always said make it as simple
as possible but no simpler
and that's sort of like this finding the
balance if it gets too complex
you really can't understand even the
modeler learns to not be able to really
understand their
model there's so many interactions that
you just can't keep track
it's too simple it's just not realistic
and so you try to find
those key central mechanisms that give
realistic behavior but are not
so complex that that you can't
understand
the the model and then finally it's
important to remember that models
never provide answers they only provide
quantitative hypotheses
okay so because they're just estimates
so
but the important thing is that they're
quantitative hypotheses
so you can predict that this under this
condition you should get this much
dry matter it gives you something that's
really testable then
so i i think modeling is a very very
useful
tool even if you don't get numbers just
uh the
intellectual process so anyway
so if you can take at least a small
uh part of your time to pursue ideas
that nobody else
either understands or would think about
or would want you to do
i've had i've had proposals sent back
saying
no you don't get funding and we don't
even want you to do this
and interestingly 10 years later the
growers came back and said can you
advise me on how to do this so
so sometimes you have to have you know
confidence in your own
ideas and this is a
another one about you know don't ask
what the world need ask what makes you
come alive and go do it because that's
that's really important rather than
doing somebody else's ideas
um so anyway be persistent
um you know i started the modeling 25
years ago and it's finally paying off
now
and you don't have to be as old as i am
to
get a result but but it
persistence helps a lot so anyway thanks
to everybody
and this includes not only the visiting
scientists but the administrative
support
and even our buildings and property
staff in geneva helped me so many times
with some ideas as to how to do
something so
it really takes quite a large team to
really have a good
program like that so anyway thank you
and it's veterans day so let's remember
our veterans too
uh yes they're they are
um we have we put in patents on an
initial design which
worked but is difficult to manufacture
so we've
modified the design and have a patent uh
uh pending on that
as well yeah that's all going through
c-tec
and theory the potential concern for
stone fruits is there's a lot of gumming
that you get with injury and so that
that may
cause an issue uh we're not sure um
apples seem to have a relatively neutral
kind of wood they don't respond too much
we put some sensors in and that looks
like that that we
fairly well grapes we you know we hope
to get them in grapes but
a lot of times grapes tend to have quite
small trunks especially in our area we
replace
trunks because of winter injury so
they may be a little bit small but um oh
in theory
it could go into corn or other plants
although annuals rapidly growing and uh
may not be as
easy to it seems logical to go in and
really make crops first
you make it all sound so easy and yet
you had said
it's persistence and enthusiasm and so
forth are there any
things that you wish you had time to do
to get another career
yeah actually that's why i'm retiring
so i can get away from the committees
and the reports and then go back to
doing science
so yeah
but one thing i always sort of wanted to
do that
i never really got around to was
in in fruit crops when you have
very low root length density like apples
and grapes
tend to have rootline density in terms
of you know
length of roots in a volume of soil uh
grass roots might be 500 to a thousand
times
so you have uh you got one apple root
you got a thousand grape roots
or uh grassroots for example so that
but in terms of water use as we showed
on some of those days
the apple trees were using ninety
percent as much as a grass
as an acre of grass so you have about
the same water use but you're
sucking that water through maybe one to
one thousand many rooms
so there's the calculations suggest
there should be localized drying around
that root system
in the rhizosphere and that is
consistent with some
studies that have been done that
in the middle of the day even with
excess irrigation
150 percent of e.t you're still
you can still have local drying and
reduction in water potential so i always
wondered if i could use a
like a mini rhizotron terran
use a mini rhizotron to actually
visualize
and see if we could see that load white
drying
around the roots in these types of
systems
because it must be it must be
drying out the root system but it
depends on the soil hydraulic
conductivity
but that's a that's a little bit
we i mean in retirement i'm going to be
mostly following up
on the micro potentiometer and
uh and also the models that we've been
using
we need to continue working on those so
so i just want more time to do those
things
back to your philosophical start um
i'm just wondering whether some of what
you were describing to us isn't a little
bit towards the bohr
model but your carbon model you you were
saying you didn't
really go into that with a specific
applied
result you worked on it for 10 years
confident that it was such a central
mechanism that the
applications were going to follow and
you could say that bohr was pretty sure
that he understood the adversary would
be a lot of applications
that's true yeah i don't
i i guess the i guess the real uh
and maybe it's a false
sentence was that that i was seeing it
not not from saying well i just want to
study the
fundamental behavior of plants
you know i want to know why new zealand
could produce
quite as much and if we understood that
then hopefully that might give us an
advance
being able to maybe improve our
you know our production so and you
described the back and forth when you're
experienced
in the modeling yeah so i've seen uh i
think the fact that
i guess i would say the type of actual
work that you do
might be exactly the same i mean i go
out and measure say lethal prosensitis
and uh maybe brian chabot measured
instances of a lot of strawberry now
again an ecological reason for it i
applied orchard system
so we did the same techniques but we
were coming from different directions
so i think in our particular case i
found it more useful
to give that context by starting out
with an issue
of practical importance and then looking
into the fundamental
basis of that and then i think you stand
a better chance of
being able to come back the other way
but yeah it's
like you said it's shifting a little bit
this way or that way
so why do they produce twice as many
apples in new zealand
um
second the apple leaves do not seem to
physiologically age
they can have their s they can be seven
months old and still have fifty
eighty percent the photosynthesis rate
that they did when they were born
so the conditions are good they just
keep cranking out they're very
productive
and so they have an extremely long
uh growing season and they
also the weather conditions the
carbon balance of the day is optimum
new conditions that are mostly sunny
but with some clouds it provides some
confusive radiation around
and then high temperatures in the low
70s
low to mid-70s
that's optimum for carbon balance so
when we run the carbon as a model
then we look to see what's optimum you
know
a very long growing season which is very
uh
very good at adapting to it they also
have excess sinks
so that when you have a good condition
you can add things
at the beginning so you can take
advantage of it which i think
climate change with the co2 going up i
think fruit crops are going to be the
ones that will have a big
positive response to it because
at least with like apples the fruit set
the numbers of fruit depends on the
carbon balance
so if you add more carbon you'll
increase the numbers of fruit
that'll set and then because
you have an unlimited number of sinks
you maintain the photosynthesis
in the in the leaves they don't down
regulate
the way you can get in some plants that
don't have the ability to add sinks
when you add extra carbon so and there's
been
unfortunately very few studies that not
been able to give us
that time type of data season but
it was a great one that they had about a
40 percent increase in total drynet
increase in yield and with no change in
brightening quality so
yeah there's quite a few different
factors that i think you guys said
when the uh apple abort and they drop
is that an apple itself self-aborting
does it lack enough carbon or the tree
reeling into carbon stress and then
dropping through
well it's basically the carbon supply to
the fruit
because if you for example shade a whole
tree
you reduce the light coming in but of
course you've got gradients of light
within the tree
so the fruit that's in the inside that
might
already be at twenty percent of outside
light then they're gonna
use even more and then they all fall uh
the ones near the bottom of the tree
to start i mean the ones up near the top
that are really well exposed
you know you may reduce the light but it
doesn't deduce their growth very much
so it's you start out mostly local
effects
carbon moving but it can move all over
in the uh in the plant but it starts out
fairly local
and then but it can move itself
sort of it's not a clear answer
but it's the reason it's the individual
fruit's response to its carpeting
yeah there is the flower buds are
developing at the same time
they're initiating the flower bud uh
just about the same time of all this
fruit drop
the first month or so after that they
develop uh the buds in terms of
all the little tiny structures and
things that martin kaufman can tell you
all about it
and we did find when we looked
we were looking at the effects of
european spider mites
reducing the photosynthesis of the
foliage in
the beginning of august so we had
different levels of
injury and we uh we looked to see
what did that do to the whole tree
photosynthesis and then related that to
the
fruit development but we also then
looked next year
to see what happened and uh
interestingly we saw we did it in two
different years
one year the flower bud initiation must
have occurred before the mites
yet because we had a pretty good number
of flowers
but once the mice hit they didn't
develop very well so they didn't set any
fruit
the next year the other year we didn't
get the flowers
and so we had a low a low crop but when
we looked at the
return cropping it correspond very very
nicely with the carbon balance the
amount of poultry photosynthesis per
fruit
during that later parking season so yeah
there is there is a lot of interactions
um between those in it
and if you so it does appear that those
flower buds
even even though they're tiny they can't
require any significant amount of carbon
but they're very small they have a small
demand but apparently are weak
competitors
so you know i i don't mean to imply that
everything is
carbon water you know it's there's many
many other factors that go on
but these are the things that that we
found did poorly
and we were able to model them
hey anymore from
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu